20 kilometers outside of Madrid a 90
year old man is racing to finish his
life's work a grand Cathedral he is
either a prophet or a madman whose noble
ego Martinez was born a farmer at the
young age of 10 he saw the Spanish Civil
War tear his country apart and he's a
communist forces shooting priests and
destroying churches that along with his
very religious mother sent him towards
the Catholic Church and being a monk but
when he got sick eight years into his
service he was asked not to come back he
didn't fit in he was too pious too
driven so what does a man with
unshakable faith do when he no longer
has a place in the church he builds his
own Cathedral some people called Don
justo a madman he is built this
Cathedral himself by hand he's bent the
first 20 years working entirely alone
it's a massive building the interior
that I'm in right now is half the size
of a football field and that dome that
source 40 meters above the town of mejor
de Campo and Don hoose does not even
done building his full vision for the
Cathedral includes two spires making the
whole thing 80 meters tall it would be a
grand Cathedral to rival even the old
masterpieces throughout Spain the
construction methods are simple its
stained-glass windows are made from
ground glass set into glue the pillars
are cast from empty oil drums the dome
of top is built from dozens of cut-up
plastic food tubs and while the methods
may be humble after 55 years of working
with Don justo has built is magnificent
and it was all done without the support
of the government without permits
without plans and without the support of
the church when the sheer force of will
take something from misguided to
magnificent when does delusion
divine inspiration has done justo has
said I wanted to build a place for God
on farmland there were no plans
everything was in my head and I have
done it all myself and so he has but
cathedrals take a long time to build
this will take more than a lifetime and
no one has stepped up to take it over
when Don Ho Stowe passes at 90 don justo
expects he will die soon and meet the
maker to whom he's dedicated his life
and this magnificent building and asked
if he would do anything different he
said if I could do it all over again I'd
build it twice as big subscribe here and
watch more videos here if you enjoyed
this you have to watch the madman and
the cathedral it is a 20 minute
documentary about Don Ho so about the
cathedral and it is fantastic it's
really really good I can't recommend it
highly enough and finally it should be
noted that one issue with building
higher is that a number of storks have
happily made their home on the rooftop
where the spire should be is a giant
stork's nest they're very happy up there